CBS News financial contributor Mellody
Hobson is with us this morning good
morning morning so is that the thing
that the economy's doing so well that
this fear of inflation is what's got
people moving out of the market in a
word yes that's exactly what has
happened the news is good and as a
result of that there was a great jobs
report wages are up and that was a big
move and we've been waiting for that to
happen so everyone says well that means
profits are going to be down that also
means the Fed is going to want to keep
inflation in check which means higher
interest rates this is not new news
that's the interesting thing we saw
rates go up last year we expect it rates
to go up this year but the numbers
sounds so scary melody are you here to
offer calm and comfort well certainly
you know that's what I do
these kind of moments yeah and it's
interesting because all the headlines
are biggest one-day point drop ever but
in perspective if you look at that in
percentage terms it's not even in the
top 20 because of the base that we
started off of at 26,000 and so a bad
day was the crash of 87 where the market
was down almost 23 percent in a day no
that was a bad day this is to be
expected because we've gone since 2008
without even a correction meaning the
stock we're at stock market being down
at least for 10 percent I'm so glad you
pointed that out in fact I've been doing
a lot of reading on this in fact the
last 18 months have been the least
volatile periods for the stock market in
modern times what does it mean though
for the average investor because about a
third of Americans have money in the
market through their investment accounts
so what the average investor is going to
see is their 401k plan is down however
this is why I love 401k plans you put
away a little bit of your paycheck every
two weeks and you're buying when the
market is high you're buying when the
Harket market is low and over the long
term you averaged a better price if you
let the system work don't change
anything that you do now you're going to
be buying more shares so this works in
your favorite favor
the average American during this period
should do nothing you should not be
changing your approach you should allow
dollar cost averaging which is what it
is called to work for you with your 4:1
so you've done lots of reporting you
know what are the largest firms doing in
terms right now so I talk to
institutional dusters I am more
nothing they're sticking with their
asset allocations they're sticking with
their policies you don't see big
investors making huge changes on one day
things going on in the stock markets but
if it's up to you that we should when
should we start to worry I wouldn't be
worried for a long time because the
underlying fundamentals are so strong
not only in the US but in major markets
around the globe all right Melanie thank
you so much always good to see you voice
of calm yes